Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
November 10th,
2014 hour.
Why?
Yeah,
how you doing?
What's going on?
Um,
how was your weekend?
Oh,
did it go by too fast?
They always do,
don't they?
Those fucking days off.
Nothing flies by like a fucking day off.
It's unbelievable.
What a fuck does it work like that?
Why shouldn't a day off go by just a slow.
There was any,
if there's any sort of like,
just fucking fairness in the goddamn world.
Wouldn't a day off go just as slow as a workday.
You know this,
you know there's some egg head out there.
Well Tech Deck Lay yet dodge ball 24 hour.
Shut the fuck up actually.
You know what egg head,
why don't you hang out with me and my day off and then it'll fucking go just as
slow as a Tuesday.
It's nothing worse than a Tuesday.
You know,
everybody fucking talks about Mondays,
right?
Like dead fucking band where the dude was banging his own daughter,
the mamas and the Papas where they don't want to sing that song rainy days.
And Mondays always get me down.
You know what was that Karen Carpenter
sitting there just eating the crust of a sandwich.
Karat white.
Ya Don't do that bill dot.
Not too,
too early in the podcast.
All right.
Don't,
don't fucking start giving Karen proper into shit.
Just cause you jealous cause she's a better drummer than you could ever be.
All right,
Bill fucking stand down.
Um,
no,
that's all it shit.
That old,
that whole thing where,
you know,
three weeks of working out is like negated by three days of bad eating.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't know what it is.
Like,
uh,
I dunno,
I become old Frito face the last couple of fucking weeks and it's like I never
did a pull up in my life,
you know,
so,
um,
I got to get back on the stick.
I'm actually back here,
uh,
east coast last night.
I got to do the comics come home.
Um,
that was actually,
I thought it was going to be a guidance Serena,
again,
it was at the fleet at TD bank,
North Gatton fucking whatever,
whatever the fuck they call it.
Where the Bruins and Celtics play that we actually had the show there.
I had a great time.
I went on last after a bunch of BS comics.
Uh,
and uh,
speaking of pull ups,
we were in the bowels of the,
uh,
of the arena and they had like these pull up bars,
which I imagined,
you know,
Bruins a Celtic,
she was probably the Bruins Celtics at two fucking tall to do a pull up,
aren't they?
Um,
and I was over there with Lenny Clarke who's like 63 years old and he does pull
ups and he fucking bangs out like 10 of them.
It's 63 Lenny class,
right.
This is what we're doing before we're going on.
He had just came off with his fucking lime green,
the guy such a character.
First of all,
he's wearing these uh,
daddy Warbucks like loafers with these gold inlays with the sweatpants and a t
shirt and he's walking around before the show.
So I'm looking at the shoes and I'm going,
all right.
Those are definitely his show shoes.
There's no way he's wearing the rest of that shit on stage.
And those shoes are the,
uh,
the,
the big,
Hey,
I'm in show Biz fucking part of the outfit.
And who would have known that those shoes were actually going to be that the,
the muted effect to tether the whole outfit to,
to a,
some sort of earth.
Um,
I believe he had on,
uh,
was hard.
I can't really tell because you couldn't look at him for too long,
you know,
without going blind.
He had on lime green fucking pants and I had some sort of Blue Pink Paisley
shirt tucked in as you do.
I mean that's just standard fair when you have on lime green plants.
And then he had on his fucking black slippers with gold inlay.
So anyways,
he's dressed like that.
I'm wearing my show shirt and we're in the bowels of the fleet or the TD bank,
North Gatton,
whatever the fuck they call it.
Right.
Um,
the jobbing.com center,
whatever the fuck they call the thing this year.
And they had the pull up bar and I was showing them how to increase the amount
of pullups that you can do by doing the negative.
She got to go the negatives dough,
right to fucking Boston Morons,
uh,
you know,
going up and then going down slowly,
you go down slowly cause usually you just let gravity do that well instead of
using your muscles.
And that will actually increase your pull ups over time if you do that,
you know,
if you do that.
And then every once in a while when you go to do your three sets of pullups,
you bang out the first set.
You just go until exhaustion,
as many as you can do.
And even after you can't bring your Chin over the bar,
you still do reps and just count reps,
you know,
and uh,
that's the way you go from 12 to 15,
15 to 17 and that type of thing.
So that's basically what we were doing while we were waiting to go on.
And,
uh,
Tony Vee was there and,
he brought some cigars.
Mark Marin was on the show.
Bobby Kelly was on the show.
Jimmy Fallon,
Jim Gaffigan,
uh,
Dennis leary hosted.
It was just,
um,
it was just,
it was a veritable hose Ho,
um,
of the whole scene.
And,
uh,
I already know,
I forgot a couple of fucking guys you had spent and when you do look a Gig that
God damn big,
but,
um,
it was just a great time.
All the Bruins were there and uh,
got to hang out a little bit with those guys.
And uh,
what else?
I Dunno,
it was just a,
my head's still spinning from being able to perform that fucking unbelievable.
Really unbelievable.
It was an amazing night Cam Neely Jesus Christ.
I knew,
I'd forget somebody can't nearly was there.
It's only his frigging um,
benefit.
And um,
then they had all these guys like made tapes and stuff.
Uh,
John Steward,
Conan O'brien and hilarious one.
Um,
all that stuff,
you know,
great time,
raised a bunch of money and uh,
you know,
I did my shit,
I got my new jokes,
you know,
I pissed a few people off,
but in and out,
it's just,
it's fucking weird.
It's just where my act is right now.
And it's one of those things with standup where,
uh,
it's not like learning how to play drums or guitar.
You can't practice it,
you know,
by yourself.
And then go out and go do it.
You have to try it out in front of people.
So,
you know,
overall I thought my set went well,
went off the rails a little bit or whatever,
but uh,
what are you going to do?
It happens,
you know,
every once in a while you go into the guard rail there.
But,
uh,
it was still,
I was still a great time.
It's always good to see all the fellas there.
And um,
I dunno.
So I can't believe it's 20 it was 20 years.
Okay.
20 years of that fucking thing.
And uh,
I actually,
this is how old I am.
I did the second one
early on.
I did this,
I did the second one,
which seems like a about six years ago,
but it was actually 18 years ago,
believe it or not.
So there 19 years into doing it,
but it's the 20th one that they did and I did.
The second one is for all you fucking egg heads out there,
who are going to send me tweets,
going to actually all be through the fucking who can we shut the fuck up?
All right.
I was 28 when I did the first one,
and now I'm 46 is basically what I'm telling you.
Um,
okay.
I know it's crazy.
I can't believe how much fucking time has gone by.
Uh,
Patrice has mom was there and Georgia of course,
it's always nice to see her and we were all excited about the benefit.
We're doing it.
The third annual Patrice O'neil,
a comedy benefit that's coming up in February.
Once again,
we'll be at the city center in New York City,
um,
putting together that lineup as we speak.
Um,
I dunno.
So I'll always a good thing.
And of course the always adorable.
Jimmy Serpico was there looking as adorable as ever.
It's weird.
Most of us are aging,
but Jimmy Serpico for some reason,
he just keeps getting more adorable with every year.
You know,
you just want to pick them up and take them home.
I'm just fucking with him.
Um,
anyways,
so,
oh,
fucking Joe [inaudible] was there.
How the hell did I forget Joe,
you Aneta who actually fucking beat cancer this year.
Um,
and he has a terrifying,
terrifying story as to how he got it.
Uh,
so if you'd like to hear it come out to a saga son,
I don't know if he's going to do it.
I assume he's going to do it.
He told the story last night.
It's fucking unbelievable.
I think he,
I don't know if he says how we got it.
Um,
I was actually,
once he started doing the story,
I was like,
I gotta get Outta here because if he's going to be to go in this level of
personal stuff,
I'm going to bomb after him.
Um,
but he told the story of how he got it.
So,
uh,
if you can't make it to giggles and sagas tonight,
um,
up on route one,
okay.
You know,
diagonally up from the fucking cat alone.
Uh,
go see Jovian and live.
It's
okay.
It's a fucking scary story because if he got it,
any of us could potentially get it.
It's fucking terrifying.
And that,
speaking of terrifying,
I,
uh,
my flight from Los Angeles into Logan Airport,
everything's going,
everything's going fine.
Right?
We take off from a lax.
Yeah.
When you look down to the left,
you see that little fucking barrier where Marine Del Rey is where Bravo airspace
is.
You know the helicopters go 150 feet off the fucking surface to transition the
bravo airspace.
We're fucking up and over those cuts.
We Bang a left,
we're climbing up.
You know,
going back over Hollywood was so high up.
I can see over the Hollywood hills.
I can see into the valley.
You know,
I saw it at Ucla campus.
Then you see a la coliseum went right over the fucking rose bowl and then right
off into the Mojave desert,
flew right over Vegas.
I looked down,
I saw this strategy,
right
then you're under Utah.
You go over the continental divide,
the fucking rocky mountains,
and then we out.
We're out of the great plagues,
the food supply.
Everybody,
that's where they poison it.
Bright there from the hall monitors.
Zoma God bless America,
right?
Flying Right over our food supply that for some reason,
some reason we're letting these conch poison it,
right?
Some reason we're going after the terrorist over there,
but the fucking ones in the suits over.
Yeah,
it's okay.
So,
okay.
Spray the big casino all over it.
Keep the bugs off at fantastic.
Ah,
just rinse it under a faucet.
You'll be fine anyways.
Hey,
feed that cow some more cow.
Um,
cut the beaks off them so you fly over that shit right then.
I don't know.
By then the sun started going down and everything was fine.
And uh,
you know,
I was working on writing some stuff and shooting the shit with this guy and I
was telling me he's got this room he has and he's got a garage right with a room
over it,
which is my dream fucking house,
man.
I always wanted to have an old house with a detached garage with a room over at,
I already told you this shit.
I turned the upstairs into a drum room slash cigar bar slash hooker lounge slash
sports bar like every man wants.
Right.
Um,
so he basically had that minus the hookers,
minuses,
cigar bar minus the drums,
whatever.
He had his,
his fucking new pool table and all that shit.
So we're having a great time.
Just a good guy shooting the shit with,
he wasn't coughing,
he didn't seem like he had a bowler was a nice time.
So all of a sudden we,
we started our initial said descended to the Boston area and um,
we're out over the fucking war,
you know,
and all of a sudden we were just doing like this circular pattern.
I think we were north of the city up by Newbury port in Marblehead and we're
just doing like this fucking circle.
And we go round and we go around again and I'm thinking,
uh,
this is a holding pattern that seems really low.
And uh,
the guy comes on and he's like,
Eh,
we haven't a,
a little mechanical issue.
Let me try to work it out.
And then we have the ground shortly.
But I love that we're having,
we're having a mechanical problem.
Uh,
but we expect to be on the ground shortly.
That can be taken two different ways.
Either we're going to fix it and I'll be able to land this fucker or it's going
to be a catastrophic failure of something,
at which point gravity is going to take over and land this plane for us.
Right,
right.
To somebody back deck there.
Um,
so long story short,
um,
I wasn't even paying attention.
That's the weird part.
I wasn't nervous at all,
which was another weird thing.
So,
uh,
he comes on the fucking thing and he would going in for the landing and he said,
okay,
we're gonna begin our initial descent to a final whatever,
blah blah blah at Logan airport.
Uh,
just to let you know there's gotta be some emergency vehicles on the runway.
There's nothing to be concerned about.
This is just standard procedure,
but,
but it's like what the foot fucky going to be nervous about.
They brought up the fire trucks.
I know what this is for.
This is in case we're all covered in jet fuel in eight minutes and we're on
fire.
At which point you can't really save any of us.
You just preventing this airplane from burning down the rest of the airport is
we cartwheel down the fucking runway.
So anyways,
long story short,
there was a flap that was stuck.
Um,
somebody said it was stuck up,
but we had to land faster than normal.
So I don't think it was able,
I don't think it was moving.
You don't,
don't you go flaps down or whatever to slow the fucking thing down when you go
to land.
Isn't that what,
how these years of flying?
I believe that that's what happens.
Um,
what,
what have we had the land faster than a,
probably what you're supposed to probably outside the envelope is the pilot say
landed.
Not,
it didn't even land that heart,
you know,
and everybody in the back of applauds,
nobody in first class applauds,
you know,
cause they don't have any Sol's,
uh,
including myself,
you know,
and as we land and,
uh,
we pull over whatever and it was,
it was pretty fucking awesome.
Pretty awesome feeling knowing that the guy was that good.
The basically just
prevented us all from dying.
I guess.
They all do it every time they landed safely.
But uh,
to be able to kind of handle that,
I just can't imagine being that pilot up there.
You only like comforting feeling I would have,
would you,
you'd have more concerned for the people in the back then you did for yourself
so you can kind of stay relaxed and just be thinking,
I have to keep my,
which so I don't kill these other people.
But other than that,
what if,
what our responsibility,
can you imagine that if I fuck this up,
I'm going to kill 350 people,
you know?
And then even worse,
whenever you know,
a plane goes down,
they examine it.
And if it comes down to being like,
even though that was a mechanical situation,
you know,
at some point they tried,
they'd put it on the pilot insurance companies.
So you know what it was Chucky's fought he fuck he wants the wrong kind of shoes
and I was pushing too far.
Right,
right,
right.
They figure out something,
some out of blame it on the pilot,
you know,
so they can kind of keep the lawsuits.
Had a minimum.
I Dunno.
I,
I w I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
So whatever,
um,
this guy landed us there safely.
Thank fucking Christ.
And,
uh,
so I've been back here in my hometown for the last,
since Friday and I've been,
I've been pretty good.
I have not,
uh,
I have not hit one of my old,
eating haunts cause I put on a little bit of fucking weight there.
I was,
I was sitting in the Writers' room writingF is for family or our pitching jokes
as the writers write it.
And um,
you know,
you know the deal.
I get like five,
10 outside the fucking zone and I,
I stand in the mirror and I fat shamed myself.
I give myself a little fucking halftime speech,
you know,
what the fuck was that today?
Yeah.
You know,
and then I get,
I get myself back on the stick.
So,
uh,
I'm telling you all this shit that I say,
despite the fact that I don't know why I didn't know anything about nutrition or
I know very little.
I'm telling you my tricks fucking work.
When you just can't stop yourself and you know you've got,
you want to eat a large pizza and you fucking know it and you know you
shouldn't,
you're actually stepping outside the craving,
you know,
to be like,
dude,
what the fuck are you doing?
Do not shove that fucking wheel his shit down your throat.
Walk away.
All right,
drop the fork.
The walk away,
right?
You know it,
you know what you supposed to do,
but she can't that,
that craving,
that sugar,
salt,
fucking craving.
It's just having you.
It's like you're not even controlling your body.
You walk over there,
that's when you just have to fucking override it with common sense and order a
fucking salad.
Okay.
As quickly as possible,
shoved that down your fucking throat and immediately,
not immediately take about five minutes,
you levels,
whatever that is,
that craving levels off cause you full fills you up and then you look at that
page and you go,
what the fuck was I thinking?
Why the would I ever do that?
So I did that to myself.
I made a game plan before even left.
Um,
I went to the airport and they had one place you could actually get a salad,
right?
And I fucking shove that down my throat before I got on the plane.
And then I got on the plane and then I was fine and I had a banana for the
flight,
shove that down my throat.
I kept pounding the waters to keep the stomach full.
And at one point I had to give it and I bought,
I got a fucking whiskey and uh,
and then that was it.
And I was like,
all right,
did a great fucking job.
And then all of a sudden the plane broke and I was like,
Oh fuck,
I should've got the Sunday.
Is it too late to order some phone?
Uh,
keep the drinks come in their suite at.
Um,
but have we ended up fucking landing safely and a,
I'm back on the stick.
Landed,
banged out my fucking a hundred pushups.
Right.
And the next thing you know,
the next night I'm doing a Gig and before I go on stage,
I'm doing pull ups with Lenny Clarke.
All right?
That's the kind of dedication you have.
So all you fucking assholes out there,
tell me about your metabolism.
Go Fuck Yourself.
All right?
You know what you're doing and you know what you need to be doing.
You Fat.
It's not a fatal disease unless you fucking stay that way.
You know,
I got a buddy of mine,
right?
He's,
he's a tub of Shit,
you know,
and I've given up on them or just given up on him.
Uh,
because he went to the doctor and he goes,
he's just saying like,
dude,
my doctor said,
uh,
genetically,
my fucking heart is unbelievable.
You know?
And it's just like,
all right,
is that all?
He said?
That's all he said.
Oh yeah.
You don't have to worry about it.
You've got a great heart.
[inaudible] Sherry didn't say,
hey,
luckily you have a good heart,
but if you continue to do this,
you could have the heart of a clydesdale.
It doesn't matter.
You're going to take it down.
You know,
Jesus Christ,
people just go around,
walk around.
You've heard this before,
over the age of 60.
Like how many?
Like,
like fat people.
Do you see?
I'm not trying to be a dick to anybody who's overweight.
Okay.
I'm rooting for you.
I'm just giving you some tough love here.
You don't see them.
You don't see a lot of like fat people like a fat 70 year old guy walking
around.
Oh that's why all this Santa clauses at the mall or either some young fatty that
they put rouge on his cheeks to try and like make them look jolly,
you know,
and then they put some cotton over this fucking eyebrows is a reason why there's
not a bunch of fat old Santa Claus because the dead,
right.
That's what I'm here to tell you on this podcast,
Santa Claus died of a major cardiac arrest when he was 58 playing pickup down at
the y.
You know,
he thought he'd play center and just post up.
He thought he'd be fine.
He fuck forgot.
He had two.
They were playing full court.
He had to get back on defense and that was it.
What was it?
You fucking collapsed right before we got to the half court line.
And right before he passed out and you heard the whistle blow for the backcourt
violation.
That's a true story.
All right?
And that's why to this day,
you have young,
skinny guys playing our Santa Claus at the mall.
See that?
Then you go,
and I hate to bring that up as we,
we ease in as we begin our initial descent into the holiday fucking season.
Oh Shit.
It's the holiday season.
Dolby,
Dolby doe.
Um,
till he has a deal.
You know,
you're gonna eat like an absolute fucking pig on thanksgiving.
you're going to eat like an absolute fucking animals in December.
You know it's coming.
So why don't you get in fucking great shape right before Thanksgiving and just
say,
listen,
I'm going to go off the rails on Thanksgiving Friday.
I'm going to get back on it Saturday.
I'll probably have a fucking Turkey sandwich with a little bit of stuffing in
there.
And uh,
maybe some spiked eggnog if I can fucking handle it.
And then a whatever,
then you're back on it.
Then Sunday,
you have a giant fucking salad.
Okay?
Then you go easy.
You go easy going to fucking you going into December,
right?
Oh,
he'd come all the holiday parties,
little wind shear,
right?
You're trying to keep it fucking level.
You know,
you got to go into these parties with the game plan and who's kidding who?
If you eat in the way you're eating and you are a tub of Shit,
you know on some level you don't love yourself.
It don't.
All right?
And that's how it manifests itself.
But the only thing bigger than your own hatred for yourself is probably your
disgust for other people.
I'm just using this as a pod.
Possible motivational factors.
So why don't you go into that party and look around the party and silently
compete with everybody there and as you're watching other people just shoving
this shit down your throat,
just know that you're going to win this game.
You're going to win this game tonight,
right?
You're not going to be the one who's going to come out,
With a loss on this one.
I'd be standing there hand and I'll fucking cakes to people shoving drinks down
their throat.
Right?
Be that guy to take a couple of parties off.
Just drink waters and just watch what people do and you'll hear people going,
oh my God,
I have to stop.
And then I got,
They can't fucking stop,
you know the settling with power right into that fucking sugar salt
fucking situation.
Right.
This situation,
um,
that's what you do.
Oh that's another thing too,
when you get to the bar,
if you can just order the water first and you drink that,
you know,
then you find,
you find that your brain's like,
oh yeah,
like some more water and then you,
you watch your friends start getting bleary eyed and that's actually kind of
fun.
You just stand there watching your friends like roofie themselves and you watch
them say dumb shit to each other that they're going to have to apologize for and
you walk out of this squeaky fucking clean.
Right?
You don't want to be fast.
Eddie,
you want to be Minnesota fats,
right?
You have a watch to the hustler.
I mean that when it gets all sloppy drunk and Jackie Gleason,
you know,
takes out the fucking towel.
Freshmans himself up,
throws his jacket on and fucking kicks Paul Newman's ass.
That's the guy you want to be walking out of the Christmas party then yet.
But you pick one,
you pick one fucking Christmas party where you're going to throw down.
You got to have some sort of fun.
Where are you just going to get absolutely fucking obliterated.
All right.
And that's the one,
your boss isn't there.
You know,
that's Skank you wanna fuck isn't there all the fucking temptations out there?
It's just you and the booze staring each other down like one of those fucking
UFC posters,
right?
UFC 2006 the abomination,
whatever the fuck they were out a fucking adjectives for those things.
But I'm still ordering all of them cause I love it.
Right?
Okay.
Just you and we are your favorite drink.
Some of your friends with the game and a little bullshit Christmas tree,
right?
Whatever.
A couple of prostitutes dressed up like fucking Spanish girls,
which she never really had.
If you really watch those specials,
you know,
but everybody has their own version of you got to respect all religions,
get yourself a couple of horses running around,
you know,
to give you drinks,
creating this fucking utopia and uh,
that's the one you just get fucking blind drunk and you just celebrate the baby
Jesus the way it was meant to be.
That's how you do it.
Then the next day you're right fucking back on it.
You're right back on it.
And then you join me at the fucking Rose Bowl and watch me get blind drunk and
then that's it.
This you'd give you,
pick your spots,
pick your spots and you give it a little face wash and then you'd be fine.
You know,
is it me or do I sound more out of my mind this week then?
Then most weeks,
I'm not sure.
You know what it is right now it's football Sunday.
It's the middle of the afternoon.
Uh,
the first game of the week is on the one o'clock games basically back here.
East Coast.
And why aren't I watching?
Why could I give a fuck?
Because the Patriots are playing today.
I hate the fucking bi-week.
I hate it.
It's like all,
it's like that feeling when your team gets knocked out of the playoffs and all
those things.
It's like,
fuck,
now what do I got to do?
All of a sudden it's just like,
yeah,
we're just going to give you an experience of the off season during the season.
Just give you that little flip,
make your heart skip a Goddamn beat.
So I don't know what to do with myself.
I want to watch that four o'clock game.
Um,
Seahawks versus the giants.
I always lie,
you know,
I liked the,
I liked the defensive teams.
Um,
and I'm also interested to see,
I want to see Eli.
Even all,
you know,
Seahawks haven't been as good as they were last year.
As always happens.
Know you went deep into the playoffs.
We won the fucking super bowl.
Uh,
you know,
Pat Riley,
the disease of more that I learned through the Bill Simmons Book.
Um,
people leave,
try to get more money.
Every coach thinks they're a fucking head coach.
All that bullshit happens,
but still the core of the team is there.
And,
um,
I love watching Eli play against great teams because he always has big games.
So,
um,
but it is a regular season,
so who knows how he'll perform,
but I'm looking forward to that one.
So that's the game I'm going to watch.
If you give a fuck.
Um,
at which point I had already happened.
Right.
So why am I talking about it?
But because I've got to fill up an hour basically.
Oh my apologies.
Last week I guess the,
uh,
judging from the 2000 emails,
I got an tweets,
the volume was a little low last week.
I apologize.
We're still working out the niches on the,
um,
or the glitches I should say on the new,
uh,
the new all things comedy,
um,
podcast studio,
which um,
we hope to be,
have fully functional soon a,
obviously this week I'm back in Boston,
so I won't be using it,
but next week I'll be right back in there.
Um,
so anyways,
what went on this week in the wild?
What went on in the world?
Tell,
went on in the world.
Fucking Phil Rudd Drummer of ACDC gets arrested for allegedly trying to hire a
guy to murder two people and they found meth in his house.
Okay.
You know,
Phil Rudd is one of my favorite drummers of all time in my favorite band of all
time.
Okay.
And I gotta tell Ya for the fucking life of me.
All right.
Who the fuck starts doing meth?
It's 60 years of age.
All right.
I hate to criticize the guy.
I love the guy.
Love the guy to death,
but what the fuck?
Meth.
Okay.
I mean still doing blow.
It's 60.
What the fuck that does do your heart,
man,
it's unreal.
If you saw his pictures,
he didn't even look like himself and he actually looked like he was missing some
teeth.
Like this fucking guy was doing meth.
At least he looked like,
and he looked like those billboards you see when you drive through the Midwest,
not like Chicago,
not Ohio.
You get into the mid west,
that slipknot country,
right.
That uh,
you know,
uh,
different factions of the Klan marching down the street.
Part,
part of the fucking near the,
the Opera Pacific northwest,
right.
Montana,
Idaho,
Wyoming,
the badlands of the Dakotas.
Great.
That fucking level of meth.
Um,
but the charges have been dropped.
He still being charged with meth and uh,
but at least they dropped the,
um,
the other bullshit.
So as far as I can tell,
I think they're still going to tour on this album with them.
Um,
but if they don't,
what do you think they would do?
Okay.
Do you think they go back to Simon writer Chris Slade?
I know Chris Slade openly as discussed.
He did not like how he exited the band.
I don't know that they,
according to him,
I don't think they called them.
They basically had Phil run the band.
They had a dust up.
Phil run and Malcolm,
so much I know about this fucking band.
I actually know the true story,
but I'm not going to say it.
Why not build?
Because I'm not a dick.
Well,
I am a Dick because I brought it up.
I talked to a drummer,
another band,
and he actually talked to Phil.
Rodney told the fucking story,
why the fuck he got kicked out?
And uh,
you know,
it's one of those old reviews stories.
That's whenever he gets kicked out,
they get this Guy Simon,
right?
20 years old,
Nixon,
you know,
he goes from fucking playing local bands and next thing you know,
he's in Simon Wright quits ac DC to join deal,
right?
I guess he was sick of playing the four for shit.
He wanted to do something else.
So he leaves,
then they get Chris Slade and after nine fucking years they decide they want to
go back to Phil Rudd.
According to Chris Slade,
without him knowing he was out of the,
he found out he was out of the band when the band sent out a press release that
he was no longer in the band and that they had gotten back together with the
Phil Rudd,
um,
with,
you know,
if it went down like that.
And uh,
you know,
I'm sure when Chris Slade,
here's dirty deeds,
he probably has a different fucking view of it now than other people.
Oh Jesus built,
did you really have to do that fucking old joke?
Well,
you know,
it's a long podcast.
What do you want from me?
So anyways,
nice to hear that.
Phil Rudd is no longer being charged with,
uh,
hiring,
trying to hire a fucking Travolta and Sim,
uh,
Jackson's fucking characters in pulp fiction.
He's clear to that now.
Now it's just meth.
Now he's just another fucking guy on meth.
60 years of age.
Come on Phil.
He was funny when I first read it,
somebody sent me a text that Phil Rudd and I,
I immediately thought,
uh,
I immediately thought Paul Rudd and I was going like,
how the fuck?
Who the fuck would that guy want to have killed?
He's a nice guy.
He's a family man.
What the fuck?
Like that one really blew my mind.
Then it was Phil Rudd and still kind of blew my mind,
but it's still kind of understood it.
You know those rock stars,
right?
You get a couple of hit albums under your belt.
Next scene know you got a pistol and a big bag of coke,
you know,
you don't know what you're saying anymore,
right?
You're pouring vodka in your mouth in a swimming pool while they film it.
Um,
anyways.
Oh good news.
I have teased the people down under Australia,
New Zealand and I have fucking threatened that I was going to be doing a tour
down there.
It is coming together,
the data together.
It's going to be the end of January,
beginning of February.
Right now it is a 10 day tour.
That's gonna win clue.
Uh,
two cities in New Zealand.
Okay.
All those fuckers,
uh,
Australian one,
Perth,
Brisbane or wherever.
Fuck you said Melbourne,
Sydney.
Uh,
I don't know what else I got in there.
And then we're also trying to possibly tie in Asian run in there where I might
believe in a not do India.
We just have to see if there's any sort of interest there.
I mean,
I know I won't make any fucking money,
but why when you go to India,
you know,
Christ,
I'm talking to those people every day on the fucking phone.
Anyways,
anytime I get into some automated thing.
Right.
Be Nice to talk to.
Some of the people are on the other end of that phone.
Um,
I know this woman that books Singapore,
but I'm afraid to go there after that caning video and considering spitting gum
out on the sidewalk is illegal.
Um,
I,
I don't know how they would react to my act,
like how many fucking lashings that would be,
but I'm not going to be,
and you know,
having my butt cheeks,
having muscle spasms as I'm waiting for the next hi.
Okay.
Oh my God.
How bruised up what I be is fucking German,
Irish and pasty as I am.
Oh my God.
After that first lash and it would look like a fucking faces at death video.
Holy Shit.
So anyways,
I'm really,
really looking forward to going over there.
Speaking of ACDC,
uh,
bond,
Scott rest his soul,
his final resting place is in Perth,
so I'll definitely have to make a trip to that.
Um,
and then other than that,
you know,
I just,
I'm excited to go,
uh,
over there and,
you know,
watch my step.
Don't step on any of those fucking brutally poisonous snakes they have.
We're actually trying to figure out how to do the tour right now because from La
to Sydney is a 14 hour flight and if you have a do it,
what you want to do is don't you see is tech the 4:00 PM flight.
All right?
You get on the plane,
you have a fucking meal.
Now you watch a movie,
then they bring you a meal,
then you watch another movie just killed four hours.
Then you go to sleep eight hours later,
there's your 14 fucking as 12 hours,
right?
Whatever,
give or take.
Basically you wake up,
you're almost on final approach.
It's,
it's the best flying back sucks.
I don't know what to do.
I don't know what to tell you other than they get blind fucking drunk and take a
fucking horse tranquilizer.
You just going to have to kind of sit there and take it and keep looking at your
window hour after hour,
realizing you're over a place where there's nowhere to land.
Um,
so anyways,
but so you fly 14 fucking hours from La to get to Sydney and then Sydney to
Perth is basically like flying across the continental United States.
I want to say it might be a little bit shorter,
but who the fuck wants to do that?
But
yeah,
my guy saying,
well,
what if you flew to Melbourne,
stayed there for a day,
got a good night's sleep,
and then got up the next fucking day and then fly.
I'm thinking,
just get it over with.
Just fucking get it over with.
I don't know how we're going to do it,
but uh,
the good thing is once you're there,
you're there and,
um,
I don't fight jetlag initially.
You know,
you gotta stay up.
You got to stay up.
Fuck that.
No,
you don't go to sleep,
go to sleep.
You wake up and fucking 11 o'clock at night,
like at seven in the morning and you just go on youtube and you watch old
Superbowls and,
uh,
you'll find a casino.
There'll be something to do.
Right.
Um,
but anyways,
I'm really looking forward to doing that.
And then also later on in 2015,
I'm going to be doing an eastern European tour,
possibly,
maybe torn in all of Europe.
And,
um,
so the way I'm going to try to do it is I'm breaking up my tours over a two year
period.
I'm figuring out this strategy,
uh,
and the tours are eastern Europe,
western Europe,
Australia,
Asia,
and then Canada.
And then I always have,
uh,
the United States is an ongoing thing.
So I just sort of,
when I'm not touring the states,
I'll just break off and do like a 10 day tour of one of those.
Um,
and I've always been putting out my special on Netflix and has Netflix has grown
and they've gone worldwide.
I keep getting more people that know who the fuck I am and I keep expanding it.
And the great thing about that is as I,
you know,
as the dollar collapses,
I have all these different other fucking places where I can maybe earn money in
their currency and I can come back here and buy a pelt to put over my junk.
You know,
cause there's no ad ever leave this country.
uh,
just fucking would survive it.
Um,
so anyways,
and plus as I increased,
you know,
people like,
and what the fuck I do,
I got this cartoon coming out.
I know I'm hyping it 13 months early.
F is for family.
Uh,
we wrote another cow,
killer fucking episode.
I cannot wait for this thing.
I cannot fucking like no thing I've ever done.
I cannot wait for you guys to fucking see this thing.
And I know I'm an asshole for bringing it up this early,
but,
uh,
it is the most fucking fun I've ever had doing.
Netflix has been unbelievable.
Uh,
they're actually saying push it further,
push it further,
push it further.
They'd been ridiculous.
Um,
they've been unbelievable to work with and uh,
you know,
and just the people that I'm,
I'm writing the thing with and everything is,
is,
uh,
as I say,
they're writing it.
I just sit in the writer's room and I pitched my jokes,
but um,
I can't,
I can't fucking wait for this thing to come out,
you know?
And even if we only get to do six a,
I swear to God when I'm 80,
I'll be talking about how much fucking fun I had doing it and that's,
that is no joke.
Um,
so anyways,
what do we got here?
Let me see if he sent me the fucking advertisement.
You me killing time here.
Oh,
I've got to love the Bruins APP right here.
Up
to the minute.
Fucking do you guys have,
do you guys have like the,
uh,
the apps are your favorite teams?
I love when they do that.
I have this one in the Nhl one tells me about all the trades,
everything that's going on.
This is not a commercial,
by the way,
defenseman David were sofsky sustained a groin injury and will be out two to
four weeks.
Okay.
You see that now I can get on with my fucking life.
Oh,
you know,
it was one of the coolest things I've got to do last night and I'm going to have
a youtube link to this.
I got to talk to Adam McQuaid.
And I remember one of my favorite things,
moments of the Bruins over the last few years,
other than them winning the Stanley Cup and,
um,
and always Bruins Canadians Games,
they're always fucking great,
win or lose.
They're always fucking awesome to watch.
Um,
was,
I remember we played the,
uh,
the Phoenix coyotes and a Raffi Torres,
you know,
dirty play fucking as the elbow or shoulder and uh,
ferrets,
right in his jaw and
McQuade immediately as the dude was throwing the elbow or,
or the fucking shoulder,
his gloves were already on the ice and he beat the fuck out of the guy.
It was just textbook how to stick up for your teammate and hockey.
And,
um,
once again,
you know,
I was,
well,
I'll have a link to that fight if I can find it.
Um,
and once again,
I was,
I was talking to a,
we were talking about hockey on the way over to the garden.
The,
uh,
the other night,
he still can't fucking believe I got to perform there.
And um,
you know,
we were talking about,
I was saying how,
you know,
that was at bench clearing brawl that I've told you guys about a long time ago.
I went to the game,
um,
I'll put that link up to,
I was at the old Boston Garden.
It was the Chris Nyland game when he took the button out of his stick and knock
Middlebury's teeth out and then he got kicked out and when he walked by the
Bruins Bench,
Ken Lynn's been pushed him.
He pushed Ken's limits.
Blends man.
That's right.
Because Lynn's been,
you know,
said something and then Lynn's been chased him down the hall like he was
actually going to fight him and then,
cause he knew all the Bruins are going to follow next.
You know,
Canadians bench empties.
There's a fight on the isis fighting off the isis cops involved in all this
shit.
And someone was going like,
I love how like these are the great moments in hockey,
right?
And it's like,
ah,
Jesus Christ,
you fucking non watching hockey cunts,
these all the goals and all that shit.
You know,
those are all so great,
but the fighting is all,
I don't understand why people have such a fucking issue with fighting and
hockey.
We've got to get the fighting out of hockey.
Do we have to get the fighting out of boxing lift to get the fighting out of the
UFC?
If fighting is so fucking bad,
how can you have a fucking sport that that's what the sport is.
Oh,
it's barbaric.
Okay.
But if that's what you're trained to do,
then it's the sweet science.
You're a mixed martial artist.
But if you do it on hockey skates,
you're a fucking animal.
I don't understand it.
I don't,
it's a part of the fucking game.
Oh Jesus Christ is with the phone.
But my parents house,
let's see how long those Gov's.
It's toe.
Okay.
Somebody downstairs.
Right?
Come on.
Somebody pick it up.
Fuck six for me.
For the podcast.
For my own sanity.
There you go.
Somebody got it.
All right.
So,
um,
anyway,
I just don't understand what the fucking problem is.
I don't get how people,
we got to get the fighting out of it.
We got to get it out.
It's like,
dude,
you don't watch hockey.
You don't have to do anything.
Just don't watch it.
You know what I mean?
Do I sit there going,
we got to get the lay ups out of the WWE NBA.
There needs to be more dunking.
Give a fuck.
Play the game where you play it.
I sold,
I did just feel fuck.
I,
it drives me nuts.
Fucking drives me nuts,
whatever.
So I'll have,
I'll post that bench clearing brawl.
I'll also post,
um,
the,
uh,
Adam McQuade fight.
And then for all you fucking hockey purists that don't,
that just want to see goal scoring and all that fucking shit.
You know,
I like Olympic hockey.
Yeah.
I like curling toe.
Um,
I'll,
I'll post the,
uh,
whatever the,
whatever the fuck they get.
New Kid's name is there on Saint Louis.
Vladimir,
a fucking terantin off.
Whatever the fuck his name is.
Let me see,
where the hell is it?
I fucking tweeted about them.
Okay.
I said the moves he was making me was,
we're making reminded me of some of the moves I used to do in the late nineties
during my roller blading days.
And then of course I get a bunch of shit for rollerblading,
you know,
last I remember it.
Rollerblading.
That was a phenomenon that swept the nation.
You know,
am I wrong?
Am I wrong?
Thinking that,
uh,
Taryn,
Sanko flat American terrorists.
Sanko all right.
For all you people out there want to get the fighting on,
I'll just know that this is also still happening.
And that,
uh,
goaltending in the league is a post.
Patrick,
why is becoming an entirely different art in itself?
If you watch old hockey,
uh,
highlights and you watch those old standup fucking goalies,
you understand why fucking actually you,
I still can't believe it was so difficult to score 50 goals,
watching standup goalies.
They'd fucking just,
you'd come in and skate,
you'd shoot the puck and they'd either kick out their right leg or that left leg
pretty much straight out,
um,
the standup goalies.
And then once Patrick Walk came in and the butterfly that way,
resolver like a Jimmy Hendrix moment,
like guitar was never the same.
Goal tending was never the fucking same after that guy.
And um,
I dunno,
whatever.
I'm probably talking too much fucking hockey.
There's like eight listener's going no,
if you want to hear it more hockey talk you,
what you want to do is go listen to Barton x puck off.
Rosebowl tailgate legend Joe Barton.
Nick all right.
Sponsored by Crown Royal.
I don't even know if it is,
uh,
the puck off podcast.
You might want to check that out.
So,
um,
I think at this point I've talked myself out.
I'm going to wait for the,
uh,
wasn't I supposed to look for that?
I keep pushing the wrong guy.
Damn buttons.
You know,
I got one of these little fucking iPads with the keyboard,
you know,
and I thought I was really smart and I,
and you know,
I hooked the fucking,
I sinked up the,
the,
the keyboard with the IPAD.
I didn't know he had to charge the fucking iPad.
The keyboard too,
right.
You know,
it fucking kills me.
That the one that fucking charges the fucking Ipod,
the iPad itself,
you need a different plug for the fucking keyboard.
These
fucking Steve Job cons.
It's like how much fucking money do you nerds need to fucking make?
I don't know.
All right,
let's,
let's do some advertising for this week.
All right.
Here we go.
Draft kings,
everybody millionaires made all seasonLong@draftkings.com America's favorite one
week fantasy football site and a one fantastic one.
Fantasy means no seizure log commitments play whenever y'all want.
Got An injured player.
No problem.
At draft kings.com it's like a new season every week so you're never stuck with
this same place.
All right,
pick your team in minutes,
everybody,
and you could be on your way to winning huge cash,
not that little cash.
Huge cash this season.
One turn 10 bucks into five grant another turn $2 into 10 grant and a new mill
millionaire has been crowned nearly every week.
This season@draftkings.camp,
you can be next.
Imagine winning $1 million in one day.
Just playing fantasy football@draftkings.com call the action.
Get free entry into their a hundred thousand dollar fantasy football contests
this weekend.
We're first place takes home 10 grand.
Head to draft kings draftkings.com now and enter the Promo code defense,
you fucking morons.
It's spelled with a c.
It's with an s to play for free.
draftings.com bigger events,
bigger winnings,
bigger millionaires.
Enter defense with an s for for free entry.
Did I actually,
I think I misspelled it.
Make it funny you guys.
Uh,
for free entry now@draftkingsdotcomdraftkingsdotcomthatisdraftkings.com all
right,
stamps.com every one you know the deal mailing your letters and packages has
gotten a lot easier.
Thanks to stamps.com with stamps.com you can mail and ship anything anywhere
using gesture computer and your printer.
No more trips to the post office.
Everybody,
and it's so easy.
Anyone could do it.
Just click and print and mail.
That's it with stamps.com buy and print official US postage right from your own
damn desk.
staff.com does all your work for you.
stamps.com even gives you a digital scale that automatically calculates the
exact postage for any letter,
any package,
any class of mail and sets and set up is easy to do in minutes.
You'll be printing your own postage,
you ferry on postage,
you'll never have to go to the post office again.
I use stamps dot Comme de Sena,
all my posters or whatever crap I'm selling at the end of my shows.
I'm a moron if I can figure out how to do it.
Well,
dog gone.
It's so can you right now get this special offer when you use my last name bur
bur are no risk trial plus a $110 bonus offer,
which includes a digital scale and up to $55 free postage.
Do not wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandyoutypeinburbturrthatstamps.com
enter burr.
There you go.
That's it.
That was an easy week.
Everybody.
Only two reads.
I think I've insulted all my other,
uh,
advertisers,
you know,
they're not always so keen with some of my reads over here.
So,
you know,
what can I do?
What can I do?
What am I looking for?
I'm trying to figure out how far into this podcast I am.
48 minutes,
Jesus Christ.
And I already,
you know,
last week when I was stretching for time,
I was so out of sorts being in that studio,
I forgot to actually,
uh,
I forgot to read the damn questions from last week.
So anyways,
let's see here.
Here we go.
Um,
oh,
by the way,
my Yoko Ono,
Chuck Berry,
Berry video broke 100 million views.
Um,
let's see here.
And,
and people have been sending me the following Yoko covering Katy Perry's
firework.
Um,
and I don't want to trash Yoko.
I actually think our band is good.
I just fucking,
I more,
when I was doing that,
I really,
I was really insulting John Lennon,
you know,
one of the great musicians of all time.
So what the fuck am I to do that?
You know?
What are you going to do?
Just fucking annoys me.
Just seeing some guy just afraid.
I mean,
do you like seeing you like seen a woman being just dominated by some guy and
she's too afraid to open a fucking mouth?
It's horrific to see.
It works both ways.
You know what it is.
You just wished that the fucking two psychos would get together,
but it doesn't work that way.
You know what I mean?
Too.
Selfish con can never be together because it's selfish.
Cons.
What they have to do is they go out and they find big hearted,
forgiving people that look the other way.
When you grab a microphone and go
in the middle of a fucking song,
it's not even an exaggeration.
That's actually almost a dead on impression effects.
Darrell Hammond would probably be like,
wow,
bill,
that was really good.
Did you listen to audio of Yoko Ono as you drove around in your car?
And I'd be like,
no,
Daryl,
you know what?
I just naturally had that one you liked that you liked.
When I invent compliments from legendary comedians.
Um,
all right,
last alimony payment dance guy.
Bill,
a million people have probably already sent you this or maybe you saw it
yourself on Barstool.
Yeah,
I watched it.
I'm always on Barstool a Boston barstool by the way,
I'm always on that thing.
They always have great videos.
Um,
you know,
some of some of the,
the,
the fucking people on there,
they're,
there's so Boston sports,
you know what I mean?
That it gets it,
you know,
I'm one of those guys that if we have a piece of shit on our fucking team and
you say he's a piece of shit,
I'm not going to defend them.
You know what I mean?
Which then gives me license to trash.
You're a piece of shit and then you say,
yeah,
yeah.
You know what?
You're right.
We got a piece of shit in our team too,
and then we get to drink together.
There's no fights.
There's no lawsuits.
Sottsass no broken teeth.
It's,
it's wonderful.
It's one of the great things about being an old guy is you see the middle
ground.
But I haven't said that.
I still love my boss and teams and uh,
I,
I love that site.
I love that site so many ways.
I mean,
uh,
the video is the greatest thing I've ever seen.
It's Thursday morning at my shitty office job when I swear my feet started
bouncing under my desk and pure joy for this man.
Uh,
I love you and love Nia.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Yeah,
it's a great video.
We'll post it.
This guy,
this guy is making his final alimony payment and he says how much it is.
It's something like just under 10 grand.
This guy's been given some woman almost every fucking month.
Now granted,
this guy might've fucked up his own marriage.
He might've fucked around on our or whatever,
but just Jesus Christ to have to give another human being 10 grand a month for
fucking years.
And you did not maim them.
You didn't cause them an inability to go out and get a fucking job and earn a
living is just,
it's fucking criminal.
And this isn't child support people.
This is alimony.
You're giving somebody 10 grand a fucking,
it's just unbelievable.
So this guy is making his last payment and he's doing this fucking dance.
It's one of the happiest guys I've ever seen in my fucking life.
It's fucking hilarious.
And um,
I do have hope that in the future when this latest push by women is over,
you know,
it's kind of like a game between the two of us,
right?
So right now it's,
it's hardcore women.
Everything bad that ever fucking happen between men and women.
It's going one way right now.
It's just guys need to grow up,
right?
We got to stop talking to him on the street,
you know,
no more.
She was asking for it.
Uh,
what else?
What else are they telling us?
Um,
you know,
we've got to listen more.
We need to cook more.
We need to do a lot of their fucking jobs around the house that they don't want
to fucking do because they have a job now,
you know,
it's like,
well,
so do I.
So I got to do the job and all the housework.
Is that what fucking saying?
No,
I'll pitch it now.
You won't,
you'll start to do it and then you'll come home.
You say you're tired and then you bought him lip starts quivering,
then I feel like a bully and next thing you know I'm wearing a fucking Brent.
Um,
but I think eventually,
um,
unless my conspiracy theory is true.
Okay.
Uh,
my conspiracy theory is basically this,
well,
let's finish the first thing.
Eventually at some point there's going to be a pushback by men about these
divorce settlements to try to get them a little more,
not as fucking crazy.
Okay.
Um,
because I mean I just,
I don't think just the amount of fucking money and that she's used to a certain
lifestyle.
I mean,
whoever came up with that was a fucking genius.
I mean how they got the,
I'm amu so certain lifestyle.
Yeah.
The lifestyle you have when you were together,
this relationship failed.
All right.
So yeah,
you don't have that lifestyle anymore.
And neither does he.
Why does one person or,
or whoever's making more money to be fair to women in this stuff?
Because I know who the fuck would cause me has always bringing up the women who
are getting fucked in this thing.
Cause you know me,
I'm so fucking one side and it ignorant.
Um,
okay,
who got fucked over?
I,
I can't remember who it was she saying Halle Berry,
one of those people,
it just has like some ridiculous payment they had that they had,
once again,
they just,
they were in the state of California,
they will make it way more fucking money.
And now the person that they used to be with gets to act like,
you know,
they,
I dunno what they have fucking crippled.
They can't go out and get a fucking job to these people.
Do you realize that this people paralyzed from the fucking neck down who have
written fucking scripts for movies that got made?
You know what I mean?
You sit in there with all your fucking faculties and you want 10 grand a month.
He was lazy sack of Shit is fucking unbelievable.
Unfuck of,
Oh man.
You know what?
There's a,
there's a,
there's an article.
Do I have it?
You know,
I'm going to get up.
I gotta get,
I gotta get this thing right now.
Hang on a second.
It's a
Maxim magazine,
which,
who's kidding,
who Maxim magazine is basically a jerk off magazine for somebody either who's
still living at home with their parents and doesn't want to get caught looking
at porn or they plan on running for political office and that they know there's
no way to get it trace back.
This is probably actually the purest pornography that you could actually look
at.
Ah,
being an asshole.
It's not that bad,
but it's one of those things where Maxim magazine,
a lot of times there's articles in there that I want to read about,
but the woman on the cover,
it always makes me feel like a piece of shit.
Buying it like,
oh,
look at her,
you know.
Um,
but this one actually on the cover,
it said a hot wheels,
of course it said and say hot wheels.
It's got some,
you know,
gorgeous fucking woman with the fucking tanned up titties hanging out and it's
2014 fastest muscle cars,
sexiest supercars in the ultimate Jaguar.
Right?
So I'm like,
all right,
I'm getting on a plane.
I love fucking cars.
I want to read about shit.
I'm a car guy.
I got a Prius.
Right.
Fucking Catholic guilt.
Go fucking buy yourself something.
You're freckled count.
Um,
so whatever.
So they got the usual layout here,
right?
And they got this beautiful fucking car.
This is how old I am.
So they had this fucking 20 something model laying on her back on the fucking
hood and I'm actually annoyed by,
or like would you get off the fucking car so I could say it.
How fucking old am I at this point?
I got it when you fuck,
that's the position you'd be and if I was banging you,
you're not going to fuck me.
Get out of the way of the car.
Um,
but there were actually just doing the background on the,
on the model.
So they actually died.
I didn't understand the layout of the magazine and you know,
she is gorgeous.
She deserves to be laying on that car.
Um,
but I imagine,
well,
you know,
a lot of women would be offended by it because you know what,
what does it really,
what they're really say it in this magazine is you get this car,
you get this woman,
you know,
none of these photos does in any way,
shape or form.
Does it show that this woman could possibly own this car despite the fact that
she's a model and a major magazine,
you know,
she has a nice car,
but the way they photograph her is this is the position I had the lay and just
to get a fucking ride in this God damn thing.
Although one of the photos she d she is carrying a helmet,
but that's probably just for safety.
Um,
anyways,
so I'm reading through all this shit and I come to this,
this article and it's um,
you know me totally misjudging this magazine when I'm looking at it like,
uh,
like I live in fucking Utah.
What the fuck is it?
God dammit.
Bill,
you had it,
you had the fucking article and you went off on a tangent.
MMM hmm.
Okay.
What the fuck is,
it was about this Formula One car race or we lost both his legs in a horrific
crash.
Okay.
I swear to God.
How the fuck is in one thing,
one of the main articles.
That's not one of the main articles.
You hype.
Well,
I guess when you go to those kind of tits enough and I might,
there he is.
There he is.
You want to read an inspirational article?
This guy,
uh,
I hope I say his name right,
Alex.
Okay.
Is an rd.
I hope I said it right.
I right.
And you know,
I'm not,
you know,
I'm not in the Illuminati.
Okay.
So I don't know much about Formula One fucking racing.
Uh,
and I also live in the United States.
So,
you know,
I watched stock car.
Okay.
I'm actually watching stock car now for the fucking fights.
There's barely any fights any more in the NHL.
You all you gotta do is just,
you know,
if you're really into fighting and you miss it in the Nhl,
just watch the last three laps of an of a NASCAR,
Nascar race is race.
It's fucking great because they don't have,
because it's fighting is still so new to their sport.
Late high hockey,
it's been going on since the beginning in new,
I mean allow over the last 10 years,
it's really gotten out of hand there.
There's still no rules.
Like,
you know,
first guy over the walls and automatic 10 game,
I guess it'd be 10 race suspension.
They don't have any that shit.
So entire pit crews can fight other pit crews.
They have like a barroom brawl right out on there.
It's fits.
It's phenomenal.
So anyways,
this Guy Alex Zenardi,
uh,
I hope I'm saying it right,
no disrespect to this guy.
He obviously is more of a fucking man than I'll ever be.
2001,
he had a horrific car crash that nearly costs the champion race car driver,
his life.
Um,
he spun out on pit row in,
somebody came by going full speed and just clipped off the front of his car and
took off both of his legs from the bottom just below his knees.
And this guy has since become,
he races bicycles and like,
uh,
he got back behind the wheel of a car,
raced a little bit,
but now he got into bike racing and he competes in marathons now,
the disabled a part of it and he's like the best in the world at it.
And he's achieved so much that,
um,
he actually said that if he could go back in life
and go back to that moment of when he lost his legs,
he'd actually have to sit down and decide,
you know,
whether or not he would want to avoid it again because he learned so much about
life.
And I know that sounds like some corny horseshit,
like obviously you want your legs,
but after reading this article,
you totally understand as much as you could because you haven't gone through
the,
uh,
the experience,
what this guy means.
And he also has this great thing about,
you know,
when pushing yourself,
like your dreams,
how to make your dreams come true,
is to set goals and all that.
And he had this thing,
he used to call the five second rule.
And the five second rule is when you thought you were at exhaustion and you
couldn't go anymore,
you just hung in there for another five seconds.
And the thought process was,
who knows,
maybe in that five seconds the other guy would quit.
And then he laughed after saying that.
I thought that was so fucking cool.
So,
um,
anyways,
uh,
check that out.
It's,
it's the Maxim magazine.
Um,
it says hot wheels and there's a Jaguar or white car on the cover with this
absolutely stunning woman who,
uh,
you know,
in a perfect world owns the car and just felt like sunning herself on the hood.
Um,
anyways,
let's plow ahead here.
Uh,
a feminine straight man.
All right.
Good morning.
How you doing?
How are you all right,
he's got my limestone.
He said me and my husband loved the podcast.
Thanks for making my Monday morning a little brighter.
Just wanting to share with you that in the last week,
my husband has made pumpkin cookies,
Pumpkin pancakes and Pumpkin pie from scratch.
Ah,
but fellow twinkle toes there.
Hey,
I tip my apron to you.
Um,
he said,
yeah.
She says he is also a stay at home dad.
Who drives the,
uh,
ave?
Oh,
I don't know.
I'm not familiar with that.
Avail of the,
Oh,
hello.
While I drive the Tacoma on top of that,
he doesn't get offended.
I call him a pussy when I come home from work and I see him baking,
I believe that is a slight one up.
He also has a thick beard and not only watches hockey,
but plays pickup games every Friday.
Most of feminine straight man.
I know.
Go ducks and go fuck yourself.
We didn't really ask me,
uh,
you really didn't ask me any questions.
You know what it is?
He's got a beard and he plays hockey.
You know what?
He's already more of a fucking man than most of us.
So you know,
he's got to balance it out.
He's got to bring that testosterone down.
He comes home,
he begs a cuff cookies.
It makes some Pumpkin pancakes and you come down,
you know,
you call him a fucking pussy and makes you feel like you're fucking doing
something and the whole relationship works.
I don't think that's an a feminine straight man.
I think that's a fucking straight man who's comfortable with who he is.
Who uh,
you know,
what do you want?
You want me to go top shelf or you want me to put some fucking cookies on the
table?
I can do whatever the fuck you want.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I have a beer and I know how to do shit.
All right.
Turning into a Douche after being dumped.
Uh,
you never want to do that.
When you do that,
then they know that they want,
what you gotta do is you got to take the feeling,
you got to push it down in and you've got to bury it all right?
And then you let it out slowly up to six drinks on to unsuspecting strangers.
That's how you do.
No,
that's not what you do.
What you do is reality.
What most men,
what you should do after being dumped is what you should do.
What Chris Bosch did after they lost the championship that year,
I think it was to the mavericks,
he just dropped to the floor and he cried it out of himself and everybody made
fun of that guy.
Do you realize how fucking much more healthier men would be if we could actually
do that?
It would be absolutely horrific for women to see and as much as they say they
want to see it,
they don't want to see it.
You know what I mean?
That'd be,
that's like the,
the,
the male equivalent of watching your wife change your fucking tire.
You don't want to see that.
Just see it.
Or I did jacking up the car.
No one what the fuck she's doing.
Or maybe making a strong throw from third base.
That's just some things that men and women,
you think you want to see it.
Yeah.
You don't want to say it,
but if she grunt a little bit,
when she throws her,
uh,
just fucking threw a laser,
right
ball takes a funny hop and she's still able to fucking ah,
fuck it.
You don't want to say it.
Okay.
Not saying it's wrong,
but there's just certain things.
It's just let,
just drives them up and sends us fucking,
you know,
pitching to the right of the left there.
Oh,
fucking stand is down for the count,
if you know what I mean.
All right,
dear Billy boy.
Um,
I actually should say young to the left if I'm going to go aviation here.
Uh,
I am a 28 year old dude.
The beginning of the year was life kicking me in the nuts.
My girlfriend been together for 10 years,
left me for some rich older fuck.
Oh Man.
Well,
if you want to feel better about yourself,
just listen to the eagles lying eyes,
you know,
because that's what the fuck she just walked into.
Unless he's only a few years older.
Um,
but if he's a lot older,
I mean,
what the fuck?
Come on man.
What kind of young woman wants to some guy's dick coming at them with their
fucking salt and pepper.
Pubes.
I mean that's a no woman lays in bed dreaming about that.
I can tell you that right now.
All right.
Needle needles,
needles.
Needless to say,
he wrote needles,
needless to say,
but I will.
It got me absolutely heartbroken,
depressed as fuck,
feeling that I lost all my goals in life.
Had to leave our apartment,
which I renovated for us to finally be our no place like home place had to move
for awhile back in with my parents.
That's always a hard time.
Started hating my job.
Yeah,
dude,
that's awesome to what you got.
What you got going on here is you have a new beginning.
All right?
You got to understand the kind of person that would leave you to go get with
some rich older guy.
I mean,
I don't know anything about your relationship.
I mean it seems like you had a job.
You renovated the apartment.
You do seem like a motivated guy.
Be One thing.
If you sit around in your ass,
look,
if you send it around your ass,
you're not doing anything.
You just,
you cannot expect a woman to stay with you.
You fucking useless as a man.
If you're not providing,
what are you doing?
You,
you're,
you're just a big kid.
They don't need that
180 pounds of fucking xx.
Wait,
just dragging them down to the ground.
They got one life,
they're going to go fucking live it.
So,
but you have a job.
You renovated the place.
You sound like a good guy.
Granted you're writing the email.
Here we go.
If it wasn't for,
uh,
for the best friends in the fucking world,
I don't know what I,
uh,
I do.
So it's been like eight months.
Got My shit together.
Loss.
Wade started learning a new language.
Hey,
you go started studying,
giving lectures in clubs and banging a hot,
smart 22 year old girl.
And that banging is the shit he's saying here.
Look at this guy turned his life around.
Uh,
you know,
and I can tell you all your friends wish that they got dumped at this point.
Seeing you all of a sudden walking around like,
you're the new Johnny Bravo there.
Uh,
but the shitty thoughts about the x still stirring in my head.
Well,
it's natural,
man.
You,
you were together for 10 years,
eight months later,
you know,
one 22 year old and a new fucking a language.
You still your norm.
That's normal.
He goes,
I feel bad cause all that crap lands on this new girl.
Do that.
So that's the first wrong thing.
You've done 10 years of sharing experiences,
kind of hard to forget and it always pops up.
I'm smart and sensitive to know,
uh,
what I'm doing is wrong.
Well there you go.
Look at this gear.
An evolved guy.
Um,
he says,
although something inside says,
do the fuck is wrong with you,
you should never say that to her.
Never compare her to the X.
Yeah,
don't do that.
Never demand something she can't deliver.
But somehow I still do it to the new girl and it hurts her.
How do I get to stop being a Douche to this chick?
Well,
step one is you're admitting it.
And how about this?
There's a huge difference between 22 and 28 and a level of maturity.
32 to 38 is not that much different,
but 22 to 28,
you basically go from being a kid to being an an adult.
Um,
even though legally you're considered an adult,
that's a,
um,
that's a huge difference,
you know,
I mean,
if the 28 years old,
you go out on a date with somebody and you go,
what's your major?
That should be the beginning of when it starts feeling creepy.
You know,
it's,
I don't know.
I always did.
I was just kind of like,
oh my God,
it's the first is don't fucking college.
You have a teacher in a semester,
you know the fuck.
I mean,
it's just,
you can't even relate to it.
Um,
so how do you stop being a Douche to this Schick?
Uh,
I would actually sit down with their first off and I would apologize for doing
it.
Um,
that's the first thing you need to do and get it out in the open and just say
that,
you know,
I'm going to really work hard to not do it and please call me out when I'm doing
it and I'm going to do my best to immediately stop it.
Just know that,
uh,
I'm coming down from a tenured dump here and I got to,
it's going to take me middle a little bit.
So if you can be patient with me,
but the last thing I want to do is hurt you.
And this is not fair to you.
Um,
that,
that's the first thing I would do.
Yeah.
I would get a flowers and I would totally fucking apologize and be on my fucking
best behavior,
you know,
for a while,
man.
Cause that's,
that's a,
it's a horror.
It's really a horrible thing to do to take out your life on somebody else.
Take out your childhood and other people,
which I did for fucking 15 years.
You know,
it's bad.
Remember that?
What is that fucking show where that guy,
my name is Earl,
you know,
I could do that just with my fucking relationships with women was fucking bad.
Um,
anyways.
All right,
so I'm not saying I'm above you or anything like that.
we'll see that.
Put myself running a new level.
I've done the same fucking thing.
So,
um,
if I could go back in time,
that's what I would've done.
If there was a podcast that I could have written too,
but I did,
I was in a vacuum.
I was living in a podcast.
Let's world walking around from my Dick telling me what to do mixed with my
childhood was a bad recipe.
All right?
Um,
I've worked at one of the better known law firms in Los Angeles for the past
decade to get right into it.
I've been having sex with money and my female dad,
Dad,
dad,
you never fucked somebody you work with.
What was that from day about last night?
Jim Belushi,
Dad,
dad.
All right.
Uh,
all right.
He's got his dick out at work.
Everybody.
Gee,
what could go wrong?
He's been banging her for about a year now.
Great.
So she's probably developed feelings for your,
as women do,
unless you've spaced out the fuck's from Christmas party,
the Christmas party.
What is it?
Is it the Santa Hat?
Cause I want to know even going to have that fight at some point.
Uh,
we both stall at our desks until the rest of the office has gone home for the
day.
And then we fucked like savages on the desk or in the break room.
I can guarantee it.
Everybody at work knows you fucking Guaran fucking tee you.
They could see it and your eyes were all animals.
We can sense things the same way I'm standing on stage and the crowd sense if I
mean something or I don't if I'm joking or from not if I'm a good mood or they
can just sense it as I'm walking to the microphone without even knowing,
even knowing that they have that skill.
It's a survival thing leftover from caveman days.
The same way a crowd can do that to me.
Everybody at work knows you fucking.
Um,
anyways,
he says it's been great and I have no complaints.
So here's the thing.
One day,
about a month ago,
our boss came back into the office and caught us mid act.
All right?
If he takes his dick out,
all right and wants to join.
Now that's,
that's a fucking situation because your job's on the line.
Ah,
Jesus.
See,
this is why you never take your dick out at work.
Um,
you'll fuck her from behind while I get to read the bottles.
Don't look our bet.
When I caught,
uh Oh,
that was gross.
Sorry.
Uh,
she told us to go home and that she'd be speaking with us individually the
following day.
Oh,
she told you guys to go home and that's a power move.
This is where it takes a twist.
When I ended,
when I went in to talk with my boss,
I was certain I'd be fired.
However she,
oh no,
no.
Okay.
She closed the blinds,
locked the door,
hiked up her skirt to reveal she wasn't wearing underwear and told me to perform
oral sex on her.
What
Dude?
Is this a red shoe diary?
I am calling bullshit.
I know,
but how do you stop?
This is like a good summer.
He's a good summer.
Read everybody get up.
Let's,
let's all mentally go to the beach right now.
Like a fucking soccer mom here.
I assumed I was being blackmailed but didn't care because I need my job and I
like pussy,
dude.
I I you like a fucking caveman.
What is wrong with you?
So it was a win.
Win.
Okay.
Let me read back.
It's the boss in there.
I'm confused as to whether the boss is in there or not.
When I walked,
went in to talk with my boss,
I would certainly be fired.
Whoever she closed the blinds,
lock the door.
All right.
I guess they have to keep reading here.
The thing is she didn't stop.
She calls me to office at least twice a week to go down on her for an hour.
She says she has security footage
of my coworker and I having sex.
Oh wait a minute,
I missed that.
Your boss is a woman.
Oh,
see the sexist me assumed you had a male boss.
There you go.
I got work to do on myself as another thing.
Wait a minute,
you got to go down on your boss.
She says she has security footage of my coworker and I having sex in the off
too.
This is a crime and that she'll fire is both,
unless they continue to serve as her.
So she's got to be old and hard up.
This is a fucking nightmare.
What's worse to this can't be true.
You made this up.
Fuck you trying to get me during the holiday season.
I can't.
Oh my God,
I can't stop reading this.
What's worse is that my coworker doesn't know why she hasn't been fired yet and
I'm afraid to tell her about the deal I have with our boss.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Dude,
this is like a bad movie.
If this is actually real,
you fucking tell her and then you film her in the fucking act with you,
your boss.
Right.
And then you say,
listen,
unless you give us both a fucking race,
we'll fucking will rat you out.
Actually No.
What do you want to do is go to the cops because then you know,
cause then you're both doing it to each other and then somehow the state could
maybe send you all the jail.
Anyways,
he goes,
I realize this isn't the worst problem to have then.
You know what,
Dude,
I don't have a fucking problem.
I,
if you don't give a fuck,
why should I?
My boss isn't exactly unattractive,
but not someone I'd approach it a bar or anything.
I think Jodie foster in silence of the lambs.
So what do I do?
Should I call her bluff and refuse to continue or should I suck it up?
No Pun intended and keep on going.
Also,
I should tell or should I tell my coworker and risk ruining the relationship or
worst risk getting the word out.
Then I'm basically a whore and he help us appreciate thanks and go fuck
yourself.
Uh,
or come fuck my boss with me.
Yeah,
this guy's a jerk off.
You don't give a fuck.
All right.
Look at whenever you get tired of being a man whore,
this is what you need to do.
You need to go Mickey Rourke here.
Popa Greenwich Village.
You know,
you got to get a tape,
you got to come in.
They're wired.
This is a great thing.
That sense,
you're not fucking her.
You can come in there wearing a god damn wire and all you gotta do is just have
her say some incriminating shit.
All right?
And then you get to walk in there,
you know,
and then you just,
you grab it by your hand.
Cause I gotta fucking tape tape.
I took off a dead cop,
right?
You give her that fucking speech,
you go out,
you get your hair cut is just smoking a cigarette while some woman fucking
manicures your nails and you come walking in there,
Mickey Rourke,
Pope of Greenwich Village,
and you'd tell the bitch,
I'm going to fucking put you in jail.
He'd give me a race.
Although I shouldn't.
I,
you shouldn't do that because now engaged in criminal activity,
what you need to do is you got to have some fucking self esteem.
You know what I would do honestly,
because if
I personally,
I wouldn't want any of this to come out.
Um,
what I would do
okay.
Is I would get another fucking job.
Okay.
And then I would just,
I would walk away.
I would,
I think I would just walk away.
Isn't that funny?
This is the type of fucking thing that if a man was doing it to a woman,
it'd be like,
oh my God,
this stays to stop.
But I guarantee you most of the women that listen to this start this,
this was a funny fucking story.
MMM.
I guess it is,
but it's just because they can't physically fucking don.
Okay.
I guess is the way where it's a fact.
I know.
I guess it's that thing,
that whole fucking thing that you could literally force yourself on,
but she's literally forcing you what a fucking animal.
Like.
I still don't believe that that's true,
but I enjoyed it nonetheless.
Um,
underrated.
Yeah.
Uh,
there are song lyrics and the act,
what
there are,
these are song lyrics and the act is what is underrated.
Okay.
Uh,
just before doggy styling,
a woman to go hunt one hut too.
What
I hate when guys do shit like that.
Like,
I never found any of those fucking jokes.
Funny.
You know,
like this is the dirty Sanchez.
Would you focus sticky?
Did you,
you will be good up top.
You know that stupid frat boy fucking humor.
MMM.
I always,
all of that shit always comes from a place of insecurity that like,
look,
it's so easy for me to get laid that I can disrespect women in this fucking way.
You know what I mean?
Those are those Jackhammer in guys.
They don't know what the fuck they're doing in bed.
They just get on top of that.
Those fucking guys that was poor fucking women got to put up with that shit.
Just someone who just was not blessed with any sort of fucking empathy,
wasn't blessed with any Sorta,
uh,
fuck it.
Ain't no gift of touch or anything like that.
Those are all,
those are those dirty Sanchez fucking guy.
I always hated those fucking jokes.
Yeah.
Donkey Paul.
But you weren't a backer.
Is He really?
Is that right?
Does that make you a man?
You fucking jerk off.
All right.
Anyways,
that's the podcast for this week.
I,
once again,
I want to thank,
um,
Cam Neely and Denis leary for letting me be a part of this unbelievable charity
over the years and watching it grow from the Orpheum theater or budget guidance,
Serena and now over at the fleet center or TD bank,
North Gatton,
whatever the hell they call it now.
Um,
it's so great and it's such a raise,
raised all of this money and I'm like most of the charities,
this money actually goes to the victims.
Phenomenal to be a part of it.
It's always like a,
like a standup cup comedian,
like a high school reunion.
You know,
I get to see all these guys that I don't get to see enough.
Uh,
it was,
uh,
just a phenomenal time and I want to thank everybody that bought tickets and
gave to that,
that great charity.
And uh,
I look forward to doing many more in the future.
Hopefully God willing.
All right,
that's the podcast.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.